Shure: yes
Shure: Yes
Jake: 开始吧开始吧
Jake: Let's start, let's start.
Jake: 大家互相看一下谁红的灯
Jake: 白灯没有亮就是
Jake: If the white light isn't on, then...
Katrina: 亮了
Katrina: It's on.
Shure: 都亮了
Shure: They're all on.
Jake: 亮了很亮很亮
Jake: It's on, very bright, very bright.
Jake: 来看一会
Jake: Come, take a look for a while.
Jake: 好看吗
Jake: Looks good?
Shure:  好看
Shure: Looks good.
Shure:  太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Alice: 好看
Alice: Looks good.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Shure:  来给AI喂点抖音
Shure: Let's feed the AI some TikTok.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 自己想看
Tasha: You want to watch it yourself.
Jake:评论评论评论
Jake: Comment, comment, comment.
Jake: 这谁啊
Jake: Who's this?
Shure: 陈泽啊
Shure: It's Chen Ze.
Katrina:  呵呵陈泽有点抽象真的
Katrina: Haha, Chen Ze is a bit abstract, really.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Shure: 哎呦 卧槽
Shure: Oh wow, damn.
Shure: 沙雕
Shure: Silly.
Shure: 成谢谢您
Shure: Done, thanks.
Jake: 好好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Shure:  掉出来了
Shure: It fell out.
Jake: 哎呀怎么掉出来了
Jake: Oh no, how did it fall out?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Katrina: 呀好热呀
Katrina: Gosh, it's so hot.
Katrina:  感觉比武汉还热呀
Katrina: Feels hotter than Wuhan.
Jake: 会是老板第一个下车
Jake: Will the boss be the first to get off?
Jake: 一般老板是第一个下车吗
Jake: Is the boss usually the first to get off?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: Don't know.
Lucia: 不是应该先
Lucia: 司机先下车
Lucia: The driver gets off first.
Lucia: 然后给你把门拉开这种
Lucia: Then opens the door for you.
Tasha: 下车
Jake: 不会第一个下车
Jake: Won't be the first to get off
Shure:  万一遇刺什么的是吧
Shure: What if there's an assassination or something, right?
Jake: 对第一个下车第一个被崩
Jake: Yeah, the first to get off is the first to get shot
Shure: 第一个下了之后
Shure:  保镖
Shure: Bodyguard
Jake: 怎么过去啊
Jake: How do we get over there?
Jake: 怎么停在这么个地方啊
Jake: Why did it stop here?
Katrina: 怎么过去
Katrina: How do we get over?
Tasha: 跨过去
Tasha: Climb over
Shure: 我们只要
Shure: We just need to
Jake: 你跨一下
Jake: You climb over
Shure: 助跑一下
Shure: Take a running start
Lucia: 助跑一下哈哈哈
Lucia: Take a running start, haha
Shure:  迟到了
Shure: We're late
Shure:  这怎么给停这地方
Shure: Why did they stop here?
Lucia: 我好像有一点点晕
Lucia: I feel a bit dizzy
Shure:  给差评
Shure: Give it a bad review
Jake: 给差评
Jake: Give it a bad review
Jake: 咋整啊
Jake: What do we do?
Jake: 那边是可以走吗
Jake: Can we walk over there?
Shure: 过去
Katrina:  盒马在这个商场里吗
Katrina: Is Hema in this mall?
Jake:那那那过得去吗
Jake: Can we get over there?
Jake: 过不去
Jake: Can't get over
Tasha: 盒马在哪
Tasha: Where's Hema?
Jake: 绕一圈吧
Jake: Let's go around
Katrina: 搜一下
Katrina: Search it up
Shure:  啊从那过去
Shure: Ah, go from there
Tasha: 真的可以过去的
Tasha: We can really get over there
Shure: 盒马
Shure: Hema
Lucia: 那个有点高吧感觉跨不过去啊
Lucia: That’s quite high, feels like we can't climb over
Lucia: 哎不是
Lucia: Hey, wait
Lucia: 等一下同志们
Lucia: Hold on, everyone
Lucia: 腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: The tall ones have already gone over
Lucia: 是这是是是
Lucia: Yes, this is...
Shure:  这这边绕一下吧
Shure: Let's go around this way
Shure:  还是
Shure: Or
Katrina: 这边过去
Katrina: Go this way
Katrina:  在那边
Katrina: Over there
Shure:  对走吧走吧
Shure: Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Jake: 头盔要不给他吧
Jake: Should we give him the helmet?
Jake: 他跑过了
Jake: He ran past.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈这能过去吗
Katrina: Hahaha, can we even get through this?
Lucia: 哈哈腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: Haha, the tall people have already made it through.
Jake: 跑过了他们
Jake: They ran past them.
Shure: 拉倒吧
Shure: Forget about it.
Katrina: 这不边点进去以后左拐
Katrina: Isn't it left after entering the store?
Katrina: 几楼啊
Katrina: Which floor is it?
Lucia: 不行我今天穿这衣服我翻不了
Lucia: No way, I can't climb in this outfit today.
Shure:  就这就能过去
Shure: You can get through just like this.
Katrina:  当时我们主要是十一点门禁
Katrina: We mainly had an 11 PM curfew.
Katrina:  他会把那个东门的小门关了
Katrina: He would close the small gate at the east entrance.
Katrina:  我们也这样翻进去
Katrina: We also climbed over like this.
Katrina:  保保安就看着我们翻
Katrina: The security guard just watched us climb.
Shure:  外面大门没有门禁
Shure: The main gate outside doesn't have a curfew.
Shure:  只有宿舍楼有门禁
Shure: Only the dorm building has a curfew.
Katrina:  那小门他会关离我们宿舍进那个
Katrina: He would close the small gate near our dorm.
Katrina:  然后走那个大门要绕学校外面一圈
Katrina: Then, you'd have to walk around the entire school to use the main gate.
Katrina:  就直接翻进去
Katrina: So we just climbed over directly.
Katrina:  他刚好有个那个放外卖的桌子
Katrina: 直接翻过去
Katrina: Just climbed over directly.
Shure:  直接啪的一声
Shure: And there was a loud thud.
Shure:  好快啊
Shure: It was so fast.
Katrina: 直接落地
Katrina: Landed directly.
Katrina:  稳稳落地
Katrina: Landed smoothly.
Shure: 来轩导
Shure: Come on, Director Xuan.
Shure:  带路吧
Shure: Lead the way.
Katrina: 啥
Katrina: What?
Shure: 献过血吗
Shure: Have you ever donated blood?
Katrina:  献过
Katrina: Yeah, I have.
Katrina: 大一献过
Katrina: Donated in freshman year.
Katrina: 我靠那针可粗了
Katrina: Man, that needle was huge.
Katrina:  献的300毫升
Katrina: Donated 300 ml.
Shure: 我也献过我献过两次
Shure: I donated too, I've donated twice.
Katrina:  然后差点抽晕
Katrina: Almost fainted from it.
Shure: 我200毫升就是
Shure: I donated 200 ml but...
Shure:  就不流了你知道吗
Katrina:  对就不流
Katrina: Yeah, it just stopped.
Katrina:  然后他还把你这样倒着你知道吗
Katrina: Then they tilted you like this, you know?
Katrina:  倒着你要捏那个球啊
Katrina: When you're upside down, you need to squeeze that ball.
Shure: 捏那个哎呀
Shure: Squeeze that, oh man.
Lucia: 啊你们在说什么献血吗
Lucia: Ah, are you guys talking about donating blood?
Katrina: 献血
Katrina: Donating blood.
Katrina:  当时就献100毫升
Katrina: I donated 100 milliliters at that time.
Katrina:  献不出来了
Katrina: Couldn't get more out.
Katrina:  然后医生就捏那个血
Katrina: Then the doctor had to squeeze the blood.
Shure:  然后旁边跟我一起去的那个
Shure: Then the guy who went with me.
Shure:  是一个小胖子
Shure: He was a little chubby.
Shure:  啪嚓一分钟完事了
Shure: Done in a minute, no problem at all.
Shure:  啥事没有
Shure: No issues.
Shure:  下来了
Shure: Done.
Katrina: 他说到了嗯到了
Katrina: He said he was done, yeah.
Shure:  然后看着我在这躺着
Shure: Then he looked at me lying there.
Lucia: 进吧哎
Lucia: Go ahead, hey.
Lucia: 那个妹子哦
Lucia: That girl, oh.
Lucia: 她在系鞋带
Lucia: She's tying her shoelaces.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  我俩给你敞开了大门
Shure: We opened the door wide for you.
Katrina:  谢谢
Katrina: Thank you.
Lucia: 他们过来是不是还待一会
Lucia: Are they coming over and staying for a bit?
Lucia: 那就先进去了
Lucia: Then let's go in first.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Shure:  他们选择什么
Shure: What did they choose?
Shure: 他们选择翻墙是吗
Shure: Did they choose to climb over the wall?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 什么情况
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 你们怎么已经到了啊
Lucia: How did you guys get here already?
Jake: 我们还找你们呢
Jake: We were looking for you.
Jake: 怎么丢了呀
Jake: How did we lose you?
Katrina:  系了个鞋带而已
Katrina: Just tying shoelaces.
Shure:  我们我们跟着轩导的步伐来着
Shure: We were following Xuan Dao's steps.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh right.
Jake: 殊途同归
Jake: Same destination.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  柯达照相
Katrina: Kodak moment.
Shure:  我们之前去那nar的时候买了一次性的胶圈
Shure: We bought a disposable film when we went to Nar before.
Katrina:  哦我之前也想买
Katrina: Oh, I wanted to buy that before too.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: But...
Katrina:  我以为我们宿舍毕业旅行会去就
Katrina:  新疆那地方就打算买一个
Alice: 这翻掉了
Katrina:  我特别喜欢那种感觉那拍出来的
Shure: 真的特别好
Katrina:  那你有冲洗出来吗还是直打
Shure: 洗出来了已经
Tasha: 看你的小猫眼
Shure: 啊没没洗成那什么
Katrina: 就是导出电子版是吧
Alice: 哈哈哈小猫眼
Shure: 对弄电子版然后再是胶片
Alice: 笑死了
Tasha: 是吧
Alice: 啊什么是小猫眼
Tasha: 试送了一个专业
Alice: 我不知道哎
Shure: 就是你透过阳光是能看到那个影子的
Katrina:  好浪漫啊
Katrina:  你们两个人
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure:  花活特多
Shure: So many tricks.
Alice:很长的
Alice: It's really long.
Shure:  然后我们俩就去两天
Shure: Then we went for two days.
Shure: 一人背个大音箱一人背把吉他
Shure: One of us carried a big speaker, the other a guitar.
Alice: 感觉这个是通向天堂的
Alice: Feels like the path to heaven.
Katrina:  真好你俩soulmate呀
Katrina: You guys are real soulmates.
Jake: 这是啥地方
Jake: Where is this place?
Alice: 找到一双长睫毛的大眼睛哎
Alice: Found big eyes with long eyelashes.
Alice: 找到了在那
Alice: Found it there.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Alice: 哎让ai来一下
Alice: Hey, let AI try.
Lucia: 不好意思又踩到你了
Lucia: Sorry, stepped on you again.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  海澜之家
Katrina: HLA.
Katrina:  海澜之家就在我们家旁边
Katrina: HLA is right next to our house.
Tasha: 在甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Tasha: Found a cookie in the donut.
Lucia: 甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Lucia: Found a cookie in the donut.
Alice:哦在哪
Alice: Oh, where?
Shure: 海澜之家男人的衣柜
Shure: HLA, the men's wardrobe.
Jake: 这得多傻啊
Jake: 他看不到啊
Jake: He can't see!
Katrina: 在哪啊盒马盒马
Katrina: Where is it? At Hema, Hema?
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: What else?
Alice: 怎么有股有毒的味道
Alice: Why does it smell toxic?
Tasha: 用这个眼镜去测试你看
Tasha: Test it with these glasses, look.
Tasha: 做测试这
Tasha: Do the test here.
Lucia: 感觉刚装修完似得
Lucia: Feels like it was just renovated.
Tasha: 在车站中找到海澜之家
Tasha: Found HLA in the station.
Alice: 哦原来在这等着我们呢
Alice: Oh, waiting for us here.
Alice: 软广
Alice: Product placement.
Tasha: 还真没找着
Tasha: Still can't find it.
Shure: 真的在用心的找诶
Shure: Really looking hard.
Jake: 怎么找啊
Jake: How to find it?
Jake: 海澜之家是啥啊
Jake: What's HLA?
Alice:海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Lucia: 就是一个卖男装的品牌
Lucia: It's a men's clothing brand.
Jake: 海澜之家
Jake: HLA.
Jake:那他是什么
Jake: What is it?
Katrina: 海澜之家的总工厂就在我们家旁边的镇上
Katrina: The main factory is in the town next to ours.
Jake: 找他的logo吗
Jake: Looking for its logo?
Jake: 他logo是什么样的
Jake: What's its logo like?
Katrina: 江阴市
Katrina: Jiangyin city.
Alice: 有嘛区别呢
Alice: Is there any difference?
Alice:让AI来找一下
Alice: Let AI find it.
Lucia: 怎么觉得没有都一样啊
Lucia: Why does it feel like they're all the same?
Katrina: 二楼
Katrina: Second floor.
Jake:都不知道要找什么
Jake: Don't even know what to look for.
Shure:  你再往往那边走走
Shure: Walk over there.
Tasha: 难度可能是进阶的
Tasha: The difficulty might be advanced.
Katrina: 海澜之家
Katrina: HLA.
Jake:他应该
Jake: It should be...
Katrina: 他那个集团还养马就是那老板喜欢马
Katrina: The group also raises horses because the boss likes horses.
Katrina: 他就运那种很贵很贵的马过来我靠一匹马几百万
Katrina: They import very expensive horses, wow, each horse costs millions.
Katrina: 然后就养那
Katrina: And they keep them there.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that so?
Katrina: 然后我们之前初中就会去参观
Katrina: We used to visit the HLA horse farm in middle school.
Katrina: 海澜的马场
Katrina: The HLA horse farm.
Alice: 海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Katrina: 哦在这
Katrina: Oh, it's here.
Alice: 我就记得一个h一个l他们家的门面
Alice: I just remember an H and an L on their store sign.
Katrina: 就是我们那个市还挺厉害的
Katrina: Our city is pretty awesome.
Katrina: 他就去年自己通了高铁所以我直接
Katrina: Last year, it got its own high-speed rail, so I can directly...
Shure: 买刮刮乐吗
Shure: Buy scratch cards?
Katrina: 直接南京到那里
Katrina: Directly from Nanjing to there.
Katrina: 刮刮乐
Katrina: Scratch cards.
Shure: shoppingshopping
Shure: Shopping shopping.
Katrina: shoppingshopping
Katrina: Shopping shopping.
Shure:  我猜到了
Shure: I guessed it.
Shure:  因为我也想喝这个
Shure: Because I also want to drink this.
Jake: 哦是
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 是把小孩放在里面推小孩的意思吗
Lucia: Does it mean putting the child inside and pushing them?
Tasha: 是让小孩推这个车的意思
Tasha: It means letting the child push this cart.
Alice:是让小孩推得
Alice: It means letting the child push it.
Jake: 小孩应该也进不去
Jake: The child probably can't get in.
Jake: 这得是
Jake: It must be...
Lucia: 不会是把小孩放在里面
Lucia: You wouldn't put the child inside.
Jake:猫
Tasha: 这这小孩坐这
Tasha: The child sits here.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Jake: 都行啊
Jake: Anyone is fine.
Shure:  我能上吗
Shure: Can I get on?
Shure:  给你推货
Shure: I'll push the goods for you.
Shure:  给你推冰柜去
Shure: I'll push the freezer for you.
Jake: 就那个水产
Jake: Like the seafood section.
Tasha: 西瓜
Tasha: Watermelon.
Alice:西瓜
Alice: Watermelon.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two, get three.
Alice: 榴莲怎么这么便宜
Alice: Why is durian so cheap?
Tasha: 有人不爱吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Does anyone not like durian?
Jake: 我可以吃
Jake: I can eat it.
Lucia: 不是很爱
Lucia: Not a big fan.
Shure:  怎么说咱们是分头行动
Shure: So, are we splitting up?
Lucia: 但没事你想吃的话
Lucia: But it's fine if you want to eat it.
Shure:  还是一起行动
Shure: Or staying together?
Shure:  你把那个图po到那里吧
Shure: You post that picture over there.
Jake: 我们有分工吗
Jake: Do we have a division of labor?
Lucia: 图发群里吗
Lucia: Should we post this in the group?
Jake: 我们分几个路啊
Jake: How many routes do we split up into?
Shure: 对图po群里
Shure: Yeah, post the map in the group.
Alice: 分几个路啊
Alice: How many routes do we split up into?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jake: 其实我们戴着这个眼镜
Jake: Actually, wearing these glasses,
Jake: 绕着一圈就重建了
Jake: if we circle around, it will reconstruct.
Jake: 就是这个整个商场商场就3D重建了
Jake: The whole mall will be 3D reconstructed.
Tasha: 场景
Tasha: The scene.
Shure: 所以那天
Shure: So that day...
Jake: 就一个赛博盒马
Jake: It's just like a cyber Hema.
Shure:  让我哈哈哈
Shure: It made me laugh so hard.
Tasha: 没有网哎 你记得吗
Tasha: There was no internet, remember?
Jake: 每个角落走一圈
Jake: Walk around every corner.
Katrina: 我发了
Katrina: I posted it.
Shure:  会怎么样
Shure: What would happen?
Katrina: 那就分
Katrina: Then we'll split up.
Katrina:  分其实5-10就是你们买菜啊
Katrina: Actually, we can split into 5-10 groups for buying groceries.
Katrina:  生活用品的那种地方
Katrina: For daily necessities.
Katrina:  可以你们那就分两拨
Katrina: You guys can split into two groups.
Tasha: 那就5-11呗
Tasha: Then 5-11 groups.
Jake: 分两拨分两拨
Jake: Split into two groups, split into two groups.
Katrina: 分两拨
Katrina: Split into two groups.
Tasha:  5-11
Tasha: 5-11.
Katrina:  5-11跟1-4
Katrina: 5-11 and 1-4.
Tasha: 你是1-4和12对吗
Tasha: You're 1-4 and 12, right?
Katrina:  啊可以可以
Katrina: Ah, okay, okay.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Alright.
Katrina:  1-4和12
Katrina: 1-4 and 12.
Katrina:  走我俩去哪个那123
Katrina: Let's go, which one are we going to? 123?
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 这是这是什么组
Jake: What group is this?
Jake: 这是什么组
Tasha: 这是食材组
Tasha: This is the ingredients group.
Katrina: 我我去
Katrina: I'm going.
Katrina:  我们俩去买酒吧
Katrina: We're going to buy alcohol.
Tasha: 这是酒组
Tasha: This is the drinks group.
Jake: 酒组行行好
Jake: Drinks group, please be kind.
Katrina:  那你们还要一个过来不
Katrina: Do you need another one?
Katrina:  12123456 我俩再加一个
Katrina: 12123456, we'll add one more.
Lucia: 33好了那就
Lucia: Okay, 33 then.
Katrina:  33
Katrina: 33.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Sure.
Katrina: 他肯定要
Katrina: He definitely will.
Jake: 行那怎么说
Jake: Okay, so what do you think?
Jake:对食材
Jake: About the ingredients.
Katrina:  他是你们的主主星
Katrina: He's your main star.
Katrina:  组合里你俩选
Katrina: You two pick from the group.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice: 我我我跟他绑定
Alice: Me, me, me, I'll team up with him.
Lucia: 我都都行
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Then I'll do it.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿嘿好
Tasha: Hehehe, okay.
Katrina:  好反正你还比较懂调酒
Katrina: Okay, you know more about mixing drinks.
Katrina:  那我们去买酒吧
Katrina: Let's go buy some alcohol.
Tasha: 对你们三个都是懂酒的
Tasha: Right, you three know about drinks.
Lucia: 也没有那么
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 我我我没有那么懂了其实
Lucia: I actually don't know that much.
Jake: 确实我是一点都不懂
Jake: Honestly, I know nothing.
Jake: 我咖啡都不喝
Jake: I don't even drink coffee.
Katrina:  朗姆
Katrina: Rum.
Jake: 都没法买啥也没法
Jake: Can't buy anything, don't know what to do.
Katrina: 冰块模具
Katrina: Ice cube mold.
Jake: 但是好像食品
Jake: But it seems like food.
Shure: 盒马的酒我想想啊
Shure: Let me think about the Hema drinks.
Jake: 我也不懂
Jake: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我可以申请买个水果
Lucia: Can I request to buy some fruit?
Shure: 他会在一个中间的一个
Shure: It'll be in the middle section.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy it.
Tasha: 想吃什么你可以跟我说啊
Tasha: Tell me if you want anything specific.
Lucia: 随便只要是个水果就行
Lucia: Anything is fine, just a fruit.
Katrina:  我想要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really?
Katrina:  我要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Katrina:  阳光玫瑰那种
Katrina: The Shine Muscat kind.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Lucia: 好那我那我也吃这个就可以了
Lucia: Okay, then I'll have this too.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  你的青梅青梅啊
Katrina: Your green plum, green plum.
Tasha: 啊这个会买的
Tasha: Ah, I'll buy it.
Katrina:  青梅啊啊
Katrina: Green plum, ah.
Shure: 这个来公共场合现在已经不感觉到羞耻了
Shure: Now coming to public places doesn't feel shameful anymore.
Katrina:  是的
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  我们都是那种视力矫正的没关系
Katrina: We all have vision correction, it's fine.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事他们不知道这个是干啥用的
Lucia: It's okay, they don't know what this is for.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one.
Katrina:  先买酒吧
Katrina: Let's buy the wine first.
Katrina: 还有那果汁
Katrina: And also the juice.
Lucia: 我们主要就是一些饮料吗
Lucia: We mainly want some drinks, right?
Shure: 这都是啤酒不是洋酒
Shure: These are all beers, not spirits.
Katrina: 嗯有朗姆酒了问直接问是吧
Katrina: Hmm, there's rum. Should we just ask?
Lucia: 要不问问他们
Lucia: How about we ask them?
Katrina:  你好
Katrina: Hello.
Katrina:  请问这里有朗姆酒吗
Katrina: 酒 嗯
Katrina: Liquor, hmm.
Katrina: 那里吶
Katrina: There.
Shure: 啊成谢谢您
Shure: Ah, okay. Thank you.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thank you.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: 招牌烤鸡
Lucia: Signature roast chicken.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Katrina:  这这都葡萄酒
Katrina: These are all wines.
Katrina: 威士忌
Katrina: Whiskey.
Katrina: 朗姆
Katrina: Rum.
Shure: 这就是朗姆
Shure: This is rum.
Katrina: 嗯可以买一瓶够了不
Katrina: Hmm, should we buy a bottle? Is it enough?
Shure: 够了这
Shure: It's enough.
Katrina: 够了是吧主要加一点点
Katrina: It's enough, right? Just add a little bit.
Shure:  咱咱从今天开始喝喝最后一天都喝不完
Shure: If we start drinking today, we won't finish even by the last day.
Katrina: 那就买一瓶朗姆就够了伏特加你说你宿舍有
Katrina: Then just one bottle of rum is enough. You have vodka in your dorm, right?
Katrina: 你觉得嘞还要吗
Katrina: Do you think we need more?
Katrina: 还是买小一点的
Lucia: 对如果有小就是小瓶的话
Lucia: Yes, if there's a small bottle.
Lucia: 我们就可以买两种
Lucia: We can buy two kinds.
Shure: 小瓶小便宜小瓶
Lucia: 对但是感觉看起来好像
Lucia: Yes, but it looks like...
Shure:  但其实你买3个小瓶
Shure: But actually, if you buy three small bottles...
Shure: 就跟这个一个大瓶
Shure: It's the same as one big bottle.
Shure: 就那种他有卖50毫升50毫升那么小的
Shure: They sell those 50ml ones, very small.
Lucia: 哦那种小小的
Lucia: Oh, those tiny ones.
Lucia: 就是酒板那么小那种
Lucia: Like those mini liquor bottles.
Katrina: 诶有的那种便利店有是不是就是这种小小的
Katrina: Hey, some convenience stores have those small ones, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 对但是那种太小了
Lucia: Yeah, but those are too small.
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita.
Katrina: get
Katrina: Got it.
Jake: 来尝尝
Shure:  维他柠檬茶
Shure: Vita Lemon Tea.
Katrina:  这喝了确实有点瘾
Katrina: This is really addictive.
Katrina: 喝了又想喝
Katrina: You drink it and want more.
Katrina:  还要买可乐
Katrina: We still need to buy cola.
Lucia: 对可乐
Katrina: 这好像饮料都在这一块
Katrina: It seems like all the drinks are here.
Lucia: 这里有气泡酒吗气泡酒
Lucia: Do they have sparkling wine here?
Lucia: 酒精度数会低一点
Lucia: The alcohol content is lower.
Katrina: 气泡酒只有RIO那边
Katrina: Sparkling wine is only over at the RIO section.
Katrina:  可乐买什么呢 买这种
Katrina: What kind of cola should we buy? This one?
Shure: 你说那种香槟那种是吗
Shure: You mean like the champagne kind?
Katrina: 听听的
Katrina: 是要买这么多吧
Katrina: Should we buy this much?
Lucia: 可乐我们买瓶装还是听装
Lucia: Are we getting bottled or canned cola?
Katrina:  你说买这个大的哇他才4块8哎
Katrina: You mean this big one? It's only 4.8 yuan.
Lucia: 就是听装的话如果打开没有喝完就还可以盖上
Lucia: The canned one, if you don't finish it, you can still reseal it.
Katrina: 果粒橙咱有是吧
Katrina: We have some orange juice, right?
Lucia: 对果粒橙咱还有剩了多少两个半瓶
Lucia: Yeah, we still have about two and a half bottles left.
Shure: 两个半瓶对
Shure: Two and a half bottles, yes.
Lucia: 相当于一整瓶大概
Lucia: That's about one full bottle.
Shure: 一整瓶
Shure: One full bottle.
Lucia: 但是可能喝不到最后一天是吧
Lucia: But we probably won't finish it by the last day, right?
Katrina:  这个才是主要是
Katrina: That's the main issue.
Katrina:  如果开了的话
Katrina: If we open it...
Katrina:  如果这两天想喝开了到后来就没气了
Katrina: If we want to drink it in the next two days, it will lose its fizz.
Katrina: 买小瓶吧
Katrina: Let's buy small bottles.
Katrina:  元气森林的葡萄味
Katrina: Yuanqi Forest's grape flavor.
Shure:  可以买点橙汁什么的
Shure: We can buy some orange juice or something.
Katrina:  椰汁
Katrina: Coconut juice.
Shure:  橙汁也好喝
Shure: Orange juice is also tasty.
Katrina: 椰汁是不是只能打开放一天啊
Katrina: Isn't it that coconut juice can only be kept for one day after opening?
Katrina: 谁跟我说来着不能过夜
Katrina: Someone told me it can't be kept overnight.
Lucia: 不知道哎好久没买椰汁了
Lucia: I don't know, I haven't bought coconut juice in a long time.
Katrina:  想喝就拿吧
Katrina: If you want to drink it, just take it.
Shure: 就是平常大家也喝
Shure: Everyone drinks it regularly anyway.
Lucia: 如果买橙汁了
Lucia: If we buy orange juice.
Lucia: 我们一会就
Lucia: We can just.
Lucia: 挑一个气泡酒吧
Lucia: Pick a sparkling wine later.
Katrina:  可以呀
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina:  这样就可以调柠檬茶了
Katrina: Then we can make lemon tea with it.
Katrina: 都行啊
Katrina: Anything works.
Katrina: 那那椰汁买的是小瓶的
Katrina: So we're buying small bottles of coconut juice.
Lucia:也行
Katrina:  大瓶的怕都喝中毒了
Katrina: I'm afraid we'll get poisoned from drinking the big bottle.
Katrina: 到时候我每个味道的都尝一口
Katrina: By then, I'll try a bit of every flavor.
Katrina: 北冰洋
Katrina: Arctic Ocean.
Lucia: 对这的话
Lucia: Right, about this.
Katrina: 这是葡萄酒
Katrina: This is wine.
Lucia: 雷司令甜度会更高一些
Lucia: Riesling is sweeter.
Shure: 这就是气泡酒
Shure: This is sparkling wine.
Shure:  最后一天开瓶香槟
Shure: Let's open a bottle of champagne on the last day.
Shure:  好吧卧槽
Shure: Alright, damn.
Katrina: 不知道以为
Katrina: People might think.
Lucia: 这个其实也没有很贵吧
Lucia: This isn't actually very expensive, right?
Katrina:  对我感觉这价格不是很贵
Katrina: Yeah, I don't think it's that pricey.
Lucia: 这个是这个是
Lucia: This one is, this one is.
Lucia: 就这一种气泡酒啊
Lucia: Is this the only type of sparkling wine?
Shure:  上面也是
Shure: There's more above.
Lucia: 上面这个是蒙耶
Lucia: The one above is Moet.
Lucia: 蒙耶的山东就是这个
Lucia: Moet's from Shandong is this one.
Lucia: 很贵的吧应该
Lucia: It should be quite expensive.
Shure: 没有188
Shure: No, it's not 188.
Lucia: 哦旁边这比较贵
Lucia: Oh, the one beside it is more expensive.
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, haha.
Shure: 不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, just get this one.
Lucia: 我们能不能
Lucia: Can we.
Katrina: 够了平时也可以喝嘛
Katrina: Enough, we can drink this usually too.
Lucia: 如果如果大家觉得OK的话可以试试
Lucia: If everyone thinks it's okay, we can give it a try.
Shure: 对这个其实其实度数很低
Shure: Yeah, actually, this has a very low alcohol content.
Lucia: 因为起泡
Lucia: Because it's sparkling.
Lucia: 因为起泡酒加那个柳橙汁
Lucia: Because sparkling wine mixed with orange juice.
Lucia: 是很经典的一款鸡尾酒
Lucia: It's a very classic cocktail.
Katrina: 拿下
Katrina: Let's do it.
Lucia: 如果大家想试试可以试试
Lucia: If you all want to try, we can try.
Katrina: 拿下拿下
Katrina: Let's do it, let's do it.
Shure: 公款吃喝天呐这辈子能有几回啊
Shure: Oh my god, eating and drinking at public expense, how often do you get to do this in a lifetime?
Shure:  而且连着七天吃喝家人们
Shure: And for seven consecutive days, folks!
Shure: 啊不行这是不都记住了我靠
Shure: Oh no, I can't take it, I won't remember any of this, damn.
Lucia: 没事他们应该会把这一段剪掉的放心吧
Lucia: It's okay, they'll probably edit out this part, don't worry.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's okay.
Lucia: 我猜的
Lucia: That's my guess.
Katrina:  结束了杨老板才看
Katrina: Jake only reviews after it's done.
Shure: 杨老板我明天就带着眼镜跑路
Shure: Jake, I'll be running away with glasses tomorrow.
Shure: 我卖眼镜直接倒手一卖
Shure: I'll sell the glasses directly, flip them and sell them.
Katrina:  8,000美刀到手
Katrina: 8,000 dollars in hand.
Shure: 而且还是属于商密这种
Shure: And it's even a commercial secret.
Shure: 就是还没开放的版本
Shure: Like, an unreleased version.
Katrina: 你在开黑一点价格
Katrina: You can jack up the price a bit more.
Katrina:  有人是想把这眼镜拿来一万美刀拿来
Katrina: Someone might want these glasses for 10,000 dollars.
Shure: 一万美刀我靠
Shure: 10,000 dollars, damn.
Lucia: 这眼镜不是你有一万美刀也不一定能买得到嘛
Lucia: You can't even buy these glasses for 10,000 dollars.
Lucia: 好像他只给高校
Lucia: Seems like they only give them to universities.
Lucia: 就是分发一些用来做实验
Lucia: Distribute them for experiments.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 哈哈谈话内容逐渐危险
Lucia: Haha, our conversation is getting risky.
Shure:  刚是不是还说买个桃汁
Shure: Weren't we just talking about buying some peach juice?
Shure:  汇源那个桃汁哦
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Katrina:  遇到了
Katrina: We ran into...
Katrina:  boss
Katrina: The boss.
Tasha: 只有喷射的吗
Tasha: Only the spray one?
Jake: 您家哦还不是一家
Jake: Your place, oh, it's not just one place.
Katrina: 饮料这也有
Katrina: There's a drink here too.
Lucia: 试试吧
Lucia: Give it a try.
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Tasha: 好谢谢啊
Tasha: Okay, thank you.
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello
Katrina: hello
Katrina: Hello
Lucia:  哈喽
Lucia: Hello
Katrina: 怎么没看见那个维维
Katrina: Why haven't we seen Tasha?
Lucia: 你问我们俩的谁
Lucia: Who are you asking, the two of us?
Jake: 我来瞅瞅你们买的啥
Jake: Let me see what you guys bought.
Shure: 平时喝酒吗
Jake: 你们看起来进度一般了
Jake: You seem to be making slow progress.
Katrina:  嗯没找到饮料
Katrina: Yeah, couldn't find the drinks.
Shure:  是要我们大买特买那个意思吗
Shure: Are you saying we should buy a lot?
Lucia: 他买了椰子水
Lucia: He bought coconut water.
Lucia: 刚好我们不用买了啊
Lucia: So we don't need to buy it now.
Katrina:  哦他们买了椰子水
Katrina: Oh, they bought coconut water.
Katrina:  是要用椰奶还是椰子水啊
Katrina: Are we using coconut milk or coconut water?
Lucia: 呃其实最好是椰奶
Lucia: Uh, ideally coconut milk.
Lucia: 但是咱们也没有那么那个啥嘛
Lucia: But we don't need to be that picky.
Lucia: 那么抠细节
Lucia: Not too detailed.
Shure:  椰奶和椰子水完全两个味啊
Shure: Coconut milk and coconut water taste completely different.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 再自己加一点
Lucia: Just add some on your own.
Katrina:  咋没找到那个饮料呢
Katrina: Why couldn't we find that drink?
Shure: 肯定有椰奶
Shure: There must be coconut milk.
Shure: 盒马的东西还是比较全养乐多
Shure: Hema's stuff is quite complete, like Yakult.
Katrina:  养乐多
Katrina: Yakult.
Katrina:  养乐多要买两排吧
Katrina: Should we buy two packs of Yakult?
Katrina:  这感觉我们自己偷偷喝都喝掉
Katrina: It feels like we would secretly drink it all.
Shure:  买3排
Shure: Buy three packs.
Katrina: 买3排
Katrina: Buy three packs.
Shure:  这低糖的
Shure: This one's low sugar.
Katrina:  低糖嗯
Katrina: Low sugar, okay.
Katrina:  图个心里
Katrina: Peace of mind.
Shure:  有一次喝
Shure: Just once.
Katrina:  味道差不多
Katrina: Tastes about the same.
Shure:  喝养乐多兑那个那什么葡萄汁然后
Shure: Once I drank Yakult mixed with grape juice and vodka, ended up in the hospital the next day.
Shure:  伏特加第二天进医院
Shure: Acute gastroenteritis.
Katrina:  为什么啊
Katrina: Why?
Shure:  就急性肠胃炎
Shure: Just acute gastroenteritis.
Shure:  我可能就是
Shure: I might be slightly lactose intolerant.
Shure: 略微有一点乳糖不耐
Shure: Plus those days...
Shure:  然后再加上那两天
Shure: And then...
Shure: 变天就是气候变化特别大
Shure: The weather changing means the climate is changing drastically.
Katrina: 葡萄汁呢我直接问他吧
Katrina: As for the grape juice, should I just ask him directly?
Shure:  然后之后就闻到那个养乐多味道就开始ptsd
Shure: Then, when I smell that Yakult flavor, my PTSD starts.
Katrina: 你好请问元气森林葡萄在哪
Katrina: Hi, can you tell me where the Yuanqi Forest grape juice is?
Lucia: 当然
Lucia: Of course.
Katrina: 酒水那里嗯？
Katrina:  汇源果汁也没看见
Katrina: I can't find Huiyuan juice either.
Katrina:  呃他说都在酒水那呀
Katrina: Uh, he said everything is in the drinks section.
Katrina:  对啊，他说元气森林在酒水那
Katrina: Yeah, he said Yuanqi Forest is in the drinks section.
Katrina:  他不会不全
Katrina: He might not have everything.
Katrina:  不全就随便买葡萄汁
Katrina: If they don't have everything, just buy any grape juice.
Shure:  我们真的按计划来的吗
Shure: Are we really following the plan?
Shure:  p人哎不是j人
Shure: P people, not J people.
Katrina:  是在买这些啊
Katrina: We're buying these, right?
Shure:  我们要不买点火锅底料
Shure: Should we buy some hot pot base?
Shure:  然后哪天晚上整一顿吧
Shure: And have a hot pot night some time?
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 对咱那天说吃火锅来
Lucia: Yeah, we said we'd have hot pot that day.
Lucia: 就今天中午
Lucia: Like today at noon.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 说哪天做火锅来着
Lucia: When did we say we'd have hot pot?
Shure:  这清单卖的东西j人
Shure: The stuff on this list, J people...
Shure:  能买吗
Shure: Can we buy it?
Katrina:  可以可以哈哈哈
Katrina: Sure, sure, haha.
Shure:  我主要怕你结账时候崩溃
Shure: I'm mainly afraid you'll break down at checkout.
Shure:  你们为什么买清单外的东西
Shure: Why are you buying things not on the list?
Katrina:  要是有预算的话肯定就不行
Katrina: If there's a budget, then we can't.
Katrina:  没有预算
Katrina: No budget.
Katrina: 或者说预算不需要我考虑
Katrina: Or rather, I don't need to worry about the budget.
Katrina:  你们是不是有人不能吃辣呀
Katrina: Does anyone here not eat spicy food?
Shure: 菌汤的那个然后再来个牛油的
Shure: We'll get a mushroom soup base and a beef tallow base.
Katrina:  咋能搞那种叫叫叫鸳鸯锅哦
Katrina: We can do that kind, called, called, called a divided pot, oh.
Shure:  咱们没有鸳鸯锅耶
Shure: We don't have a divided pot.
Katrina:  也那搞两锅呗
Katrina: Then just use two pots.
Shure:  搞两个6个人搞两个锅
Shure: Two pots for six people?
Katrina:  有有两个锅吗
Katrina: Do we have two pots?
Shure:  啊有
Shure: Ah, we do.
Shure:  那肯定有
Shure: We definitely do.
Shure:  随便拿一个
Shure: Just grab one.
Shure:  这一看就很牛逼的样子
Shure: This looks really awesome.
Shure:  就拿这个
Shure: Let's take this one.
Katrina:  怎么没看见元气森林
Katrina: Why can't I see the Yuanqi Forest drinks?
Shure: 希望你们不要背着我偷偷吃火锅
Shure: Hope you guys aren't secretly eating hotpot without me.
Shure: 不要今晚吃好吗
Shure: Don't eat it tonight, okay?
Lucia: 今晚应该来不及吃放心吧
Lucia: We probably won't have time to eat tonight, don't worry.
Katrina:  你好请问那个元气森林的葡萄汁在哪呀
Katrina: Hi, excuse me, where's the Yuanqi Forest grape juice?
Katrina: 葡萄水
Katrina: The grape water.
Katrina:  对没看到
Katrina: Yeah, I don't see it.
Katrina:  那汇源果汁呢
Katrina: How about the Huiyuan juice?
Katrina:  就没有
Shure:  那就买那个盒马的桃汁也一样
Shure: Then just buy the Hema peach juice, it's the same.
Katrina:  那就买个桃汁
Katrina: Then let's get the peach juice.
Katrina:  买个葡萄汁算了
Katrina: Might as well get the grape juice.
Katrina:  他们是不是有什么
Katrina: Do they have any...
Shure: 买点苏打水
Shure: Buy some soda water.
Katrina: 品牌利益
Katrina: Brand preference?
Shure: 然后苏打苏打水然后和那什么
Shure: Then soda, soda water, and what else...
Shure: 就一个道理的
Shure: It's the same thing.
Katrina: 苏打水和什么
Katrina: Soda water and what?
Shure: 苏打水和葡萄汁那不就是
Shure: Soda water and grape juice, isn't that...
Shure:  元气森林吗
Shure: Yuanqi Forest?
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  这是葡萄吗
Katrina: Is this grape?
Katrina:  啊这是可乐
Katrina: Ah, this is cola.
Lucia: 可乐味
Lucia: Cola flavor.
Katrina:  那买这个葡萄啊这是胡萝卜跟葡萄算了
Katrina: Then buy this grape... ah, it's carrot and grape, forget it.
Katrina: 这有点
Katrina: This is a bit...
Katrina: 葡萄味道在里面
Katrina: There's grape flavor in it.
Shure: 那你买那个美汁源的那个葡萄汁
Shure: Then buy the Minute Maid grape juice.
Katrina: 美汁源他说没有啊盒马没有美汁源
Katrina: He said there's no Minute Maid, Hema doesn't have it.
Shure: 不还有果粒橙嘛
Shure: Isn't there still some pulp orange juice?
Katrina:  哦不是说错了
Katrina: Oh, I misspoke.
Katrina:  没有汇源
Katrina: No Huiyuan.
Katrina: 买它这是桑葚这也不是葡萄
Katrina: Let's buy this, it's mulberry, not grape.
Katrina: 葡萄汁呢
Katrina: Where's the grape juice?
Shure: 把 j人掰直随便拿
Shure: Just take whatever's there.
Shure: 就这个一样的
Shure: This one, it's the same.
Katrina: 但他有胡萝卜的味道诶
Katrina: But it has a carrot taste.
Shure: 没事不好喝就干喝了吧
Shure: It's okay, if it's bad, just drink it anyway.
Katrina: 啊行拿吧
Katrina: Ah, okay, go ahead and grab it.
Katrina: 可乐维他柠檬葡萄汁养乐多西柚味水溶C
Katrina: Coke, Vita Lemon, grape juice, Yakult, grapefruit flavor, Vitamin C water.
Katrina: 这什么呀奥苏打水
Katrina: What's this? Oh, soda water.
Shure: 苏打水
Shure: Soda water.
Katrina: 椰汁要哪个啊椰奶啊桃跟西柚味
Katrina: Which one do you want for coconut milk? Peach or grapefruit flavor?
Shure: 椰奶这不是椰奶
Shure: Coconut milk, this isn't coconut milk.
Katrina: 桃跟西柚味
Katrina: Peach and grapefruit flavor.
Katrina: 椰奶拿这个
Katrina: I'll take this coconut milk.
Lucia: 这个不是太大了吗
Lucia: Isn't this too big?
Katrina: 没有小的呀
Katrina: There's no smaller one.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one.
Katrina:  我靠他两罐起卖
Katrina: Oh wow, they sell it in pairs.
Lucia: 就是为什么会两罐起卖啊
Lucia: Why do they sell it in pairs?
Lucia: 我尝一下
Lucia: Let me try it.
Lucia: 可瓦达是用椰汁还是是用椰奶
Lucia: Is it made with coconut juice or coconut milk?
Katrina:  桃跟西柚味
Katrina: Peach and grapefruit flavor.
Shure:  这什么水啊 9.3ph
Shure: What's this water? 9.3 pH.
Shure: 快问快答ph9.3是碱性还是酸性
Shure: Quick question, is pH 9.3 alkaline or acidic?
Katrina:  我没学化学
Katrina: I didn't study chemistry.
Katrina:  我们江苏只学两门
Katrina: We only studied two subjects in Jiangsu.
Katrina:  我是最后一年江苏卷
Katrina: I was the last year of the Jiangsu exam.
Katrina:  我就考300多分
Katrina: I only scored over 300 points.
Shure:  满分多少500
Shure: What's the full score, 500?
Lucia: 似乎是
Lucia: I think so.
Katrina: 480
Katrina: 480.
Lucia: 按照网上的说的是椰奶
Lucia: According to the internet, it says coconut milk.
Lucia: 椰奶或者椰浆的意思
Lucia: It means coconut milk or coconut cream.
Shure:  他那个椰树牌椰汁我从小喝到大
Shure:  应该也可以
Shure: It should be fine.
Lucia: 应该也行那个感觉比较像椰浆
Lucia: It should be okay, that one feels more like coconut cream.
Lucia: 椰汁应该那种比较清的是椰汁吧
Lucia: The clearer one should be coconut juice, right?
Katrina: 冷藏区
Katrina: The refrigerated section.
Shure:  你是不是要coffee来着
Shure: Didn't you want some coffee?
Katrina: 西柚味的话拿哪个代替啊
Katrina: If it's grapefruit flavor, which one should we replace it with?
Shure: 西柚这个也行
Shure: This grapefruit one is fine too.
Katrina: 红的行
Katrina: The red one is fine.
Shure:  j人已经
Shure: People are already...
Shure:  快快那什么了
Shure: Hurry up, get it done.
Katrina:  居然找不到这几个这么长见的
Katrina: I can't believe we can't find these common items.
Shure:  快麻了
Shure: Hurry up, I'm getting numb.
Shure:  所有的全是代替的
Shure: Everything is a substitute.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Shure:  除了养乐多
Shure: Except for Yakult.
Lucia: 没关系我们可以调整一下计划
Lucia: It's okay, we can adjust the plan.
Katrina: 买不到 正品
Katrina: Couldn't get the original.
Shure: 都一个味咱就喝吧
Shure: They all taste the same, let's just drink it.
Katrina:  桃
Katrina: Peach.
Shure:  一喝一个不吱声
Shure: One sip and no one will say a word.
Katrina:  一喝一个中毒啊
Katrina: One sip and we'll be poisoned.
Shure:  这晚上你就试试
Shure: Try it tonight.
Katrina:  桃汁呢那边
Katrina:  哦那边还有一个
Katrina: Oh, there's another one over there.
Katrina:  感觉盒马也不是特别大哎
Katrina: Hema isn't that big, huh.
Katrina:  呀呀呀
Katrina: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure:  啊鸡蛋他们买了吗
Shure: Did they buy the eggs?
Katrina: 他们应该会买
Katrina: They probably did.
Shure:  生食鸡蛋这种
Shure: Raw eggs, you know.
Lucia: 看到他们了
Lucia: I see them.
Shure: 你们买鸡蛋了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy the eggs?
Shure:  你们买鸡蛋了吗
Shure: Did you buy the eggs?
Jake: 买鸡蛋了
Jake: Bought the eggs.
Jake: 买了无菌蛋
Jake: Bought sterile eggs.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  我们买了两个火锅底料
Shure: We bought two hotpot bases.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hotpot bases.
Katrina: 没有桃汁啊
Katrina: No peach juice.
Shure:  完了我们j人崩溃了
Shure: Oh no, our J person is breaking down.
Jake: 我们好像我们我们分到了个
Jake: It seems like we got a weird task.
Shure: 气的跳脚脚了
Shure: Jumping in frustration.
Jake: 什么奇怪的任务来着
Jake: What strange task was it?
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 扎死人
Shure: Deadly one.
Katrina: 这么普通的品牌都没有吗
Jake:美纹纸美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What's masking tape?
Alice:美纹纸这有吗
Alice: Do they have masking tape here?
Katrina:  美文纸美文纸
Katrina: Masking tape, masking tape.
Lucia:美纹纸这这里面能买到吗
Lucia: Can we buy masking tape here?
Jake: 美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What's masking tape?
Katrina: 就贴墙上不留痕的那贴纸
Katrina: It's the kind that doesn't leave marks on the wall.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 要不直接上网买吧
Katrina: How about we just buy it online?
Katrina: 跟那海报一起嘛嗯
Katrina: Along with that poster, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嗯啊我觉得文具店也会有
Tasha: Hmm, I think the stationery store might have it too.
Katrina: 冰块模具还没买
Katrina: We still haven't bought the ice cube mold.
Katrina:  但这有我们感觉全是买吃的地方
Katrina: But it feels like we're only buying food here.
Shure:  够呛呦冰块模具
Shure: It's unlikely they have ice cube molds.
Katrina: 盒马是不是主营饮食啊
Katrina: Isn't Hema mainly about food?
Shure: 对生鲜类
Shure: Yes, fresh food.
Katrina: 那就直接叫美团外送吧
Katrina: Then let's just use Meituan for delivery.
Shure: 美团外送可以
Shure: Meituan delivery works.
Katrina: 冰块模具打孔器彩笔
Katrina: Ice cube mold, hole puncher, colored pens.
Shure:  或者直接美团买冰得了
Shure: Or we could just buy ice directly from Meituan.
Katrina:  美团可以买冰吗
Katrina: Can Meituan deliver ice?
Katrina: 他运过来不会化吗
Katrina: Won't it melt during delivery?
Shure:  可以的
Shure: It can be done.
Alice:因为它比较沉
Alice: Because it's heavy.
Katrina:  柠檬片没买
Katrina: We haven't bought lemon slices.
Lucia: 是要那种
Lucia: Do you need the processed kind?
Lucia: 就是加工过的柠檬片还是鲜柠檬那种
Lucia: Or fresh lemons?
Shure: 直接买柠檬然后切了就行咱们有刀
Shure: Just buy lemons and slice them, we have knives.
Katrina: 直接买柠檬也行
Katrina: Buying fresh lemons is fine too.
Shure:  不好意思哈哈哈
Shure: Sorry, haha.
Katrina: 窝窝头是不是
Katrina: Cornbread, right?
Shure:  是窝窝头还是土豆
Shure: Is it cornbread or potatoes?
Shure:  流心包
Shure: Flowing heart buns.
Shure: 私密马赛
Shure: Si Mi Ma Sai.
Katrina: 柠檬
Katrina: Lemons.
Shure: 柠檬肯定有
Shure: There'll definitely be lemons.
Lucia: 青柠
Lucia: Limes.
Lucia: 这个是青柠檬吗
Lucia: Are these limes?
Katrina: 青柠更适合还是柠檬更适合
Katrina: Are limes better or lemons better?
Shure: 都来
Shure: Get both.
Lucia: 都还行哎
Lucia: Both are fine.
Katrina: 哎爽快
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina:  笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Lucia: 这才4块6啊
Lucia: It's only 4.6 yuan?
Katrina: 这放这放饮品里是不是好喝
Katrina: Would this taste good if we put it in a drink?
Shure: 哦小小小小青柠吧
Shure: Oh, like a small lime?
Lucia: 整个放进去
Lucia: Just put the whole thing in.
Katrina: 这好
Katrina: That's good.
Lucia: 然后普通青柠就跟你们一样切片
Lucia: Then we just slice the regular lime like you guys.
Shure:  lemon
Shure: Lemon.
Shure:  i wonder how
Shure: I wonder how.
Shure:  i wonder why
Shure: I wonder why.
Katrina:  彩笔打孔器这玩意会有吗
Katrina: Do you think they'll have a colored pencil punch?
Shure:  打孔器彩笔这种
Shure:  文具的应该这都没有
Shure: They probably don't have that in stationery.
Katrina: 那冰块
Katrina: How about ice cubes?
Lucia: 那些实在不行
Lucia: If they don't have it...
Lucia: 感觉在淘宝上买也来得及
Lucia: We can always buy it on Taobao.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Katrina: 这是干什么的
Katrina: What's this for?
Katrina: 打包吗他们在
Katrina: Are they packing?
Katrina: 那就没了
Katrina: That's all then.
Katrina: 我们就主要采购酒的东西
Katrina: We're mainly here to get stuff for the drinks.
Katrina: 那看看还有啥想吃的买
Katrina: Let's see if there's anything else we want to eat.
Shure: 我就不信这没有桃汁吗
Shure: I can't believe they don't have peach juice.
Katrina: 哦饮料在这呢
Katrina: Oh, the drinks are here.
Shure: 没有真没有
Shure: No, they really don't have it.
Katrina:  桃汁没有我靠
Katrina: No peach juice, damn.
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nope.
Katrina:  受不了
Katrina: Unbelievable.
Katrina:  怎么可能会没有桃汁
Katrina: How can they not have peach juice?
Katrina:  哎这是葡萄汁吧
Katrina: Hey, this is grape juice.
Katrina: 我靠这也太大了
Katrina: Whoa, this is huge.
Katrina:  这也有葡萄汁哦
Katrina: There's grape juice here too.
Katrina: 我们拿的是什么啊哦那个
Katrina: What did we get? Oh, that one.
Shure:  葡萄胡萝卜
Shure: Grape carrot.
Katrina: 也行
Katrina: That works.
Shure: 那把这放回去吧换这个
Shure: Let's put this back and get that one.
Katrina: 我们拿瓶小的
Katrina: Let's get a small bottle.
Katrina: 这个葡萄汁
Katrina: This grape juice.
Katrina: 这感觉很正宗啊
Katrina: This looks really authentic.
Katrina: 很浓的葡萄感觉
Katrina: Very strong grape flavor.
Shure:  真没有桃汁啊
Shure: They really don't have peach juice?
Katrina: 为什么呢
Katrina: Why though?
Katrina:  这个啊这椰奶也太大了
Katrina: Wow, this coconut milk is huge.
Katrina: 你好这边没有桃汁吗
Katrina: Hi, do you have any peach juice here?
Katrina: 啊好
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  没有桃汁
Katrina: No peach juice.
Katrina:  我也没看转一圈了
Katrina: I didn't see any after walking around.
Katrina: 可乐柠檬维他葡萄汁养乐多水溶西柚味椰汁桃汁
Katrina: Cola, lemon, Vita grape juice, Yakult, grapefruit flavored water, coconut milk, peach juice.
Katrina:  冰
Katrina: Ice.
Katrina: 打孔器彩笔
Katrina: Hole puncher, markers.
Katrina:  回去买打孔器彩笔
Lucia: 放回去了吗已经
Lucia: Did you put it back already?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: It's gone.
Shure: 没了吧 没了吗j人
Shure: It's gone, right? Is it gone?
Katrina:  没了
Katrina: It's gone.
Katrina:  那就找他们去
Katrina: Let's go find them.
Shure:  走吧j人
Shure: Let's go.
Lucia: 哎刚好碰到你们
Lucia: Hey, we just ran into you.
Katrina:  买完了
Katrina: We're done shopping.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina:  有两个没有
Katrina: We couldn't find two things.
Katrina:  没有有两
Katrina: We didn't get two things.
Katrina: 笔没有
Katrina: No pens.
Jake: 买肉了吗
Jake: Did you buy meat?
Jake:火锅什么的他们要
Jake: They want hotpot stuff.
Katrina:  那去去买火锅的食材是吧
Katrina: So we need to buy hotpot ingredients, right?
Alice:我们买葱蒜了
Alice: We bought some green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  啊葱蒜
Katrina: Ah, green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  那我们去买火锅食材
Katrina: Okay, let's go buy hotpot ingredients.
Jake:肉在那去吧
Jake: Meat is over there, go ahead.
Katrina: 那那种什么肥牛卷啥的可以
Shure:  烤肉的也要买一下
Shure: We should get some BBQ stuff too.
Katrina: 那个放冰箱应该可以放两天吧
Katrina: That should be fine in the fridge for two days, right?
Lucia: 呃一直得走那个牛卷
Lucia: Uh, we should take the beef rolls.
Katrina: 对因为他不在
Katrina: 今晚不能吃啊
Katrina: We can't eat it tonight.
Alice:不对他们还在买火锅食材呢
Alice: No, they're still buying hotpot ingredients.
Lucia: 应该可以吧放两天
Lucia: It should be okay for two days.
Lucia: 放两天应该没事了
Lucia: Two days should be fine.
Lucia: 但如果我们烧烤是最后一天烤的话
Lucia: But if we BBQ on the last day...
Lucia: 感觉不需要今天买
Lucia: Feels like we don't need to buy it today.
Katrina: 不搞烧烤吧
Katrina: No barbecue, right?
Katrina: 他们不是说
Katrina: Didn't they say
Jake:放得下不小冰箱
Jake: It fits in the small fridge.
Katrina: 就买买火锅的食材
Katrina: Let's just buy ingredients for hotpot.
Shure:  在这呢火锅的肉
Shure: The hotpot meat is here.
Lucia: 烧烤的话最后一天才用
Lucia: For barbecue, we only need it on the last day.
Lucia: 咱中间应该还会再出来
Lucia: We should come out again in between.
Katrina: 肉肉肉肉肉
Katrina: Meat, meat, meat, meat, meat.
Lucia: 趁着他们还没起床
Lucia: While they are still asleep,
Lucia: 先 先下楼烤两串
Lucia: let's go downstairs and grill a few skewers first.
Shure:  这是烤肉的吧
Shure: This is for grilling, right?
Katrina: 这能
Katrina: Can this
Lucia: 日式烤肉片
Lucia: Japanese grilled meat slices.
Katrina: 火锅要找薄一点的
Katrina: For hotpot, we need thinner slices.
Lucia: 这个应该是涮的
Lucia: This should be for boiling.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  我有闹钟响了
Katrina: My alarm went off.
Katrina:  吓我一跳
Katrina: It startled me.
Lucia: 这到底是他们的longJackchen
Lucia: So, is this their longJackchen
Lucia: 还是什么东西啊
Lucia: or something else?
Shure:  是这个吧
Shure: It's this one, right?
Shure:  我早上听得一清二楚
Shure: I heard it clearly this morning.
Katrina:  真假
Katrina: Really?
Shure:  我就知道
Shure: I just knew it.
Shure:  哪个倒霉蛋是闹钟自己没没醒
Shure: Who's the unlucky one who didn't wake up because of the alarm?
Shure:  因为那个真的特别不容易醒
Shure: Because it's really hard to wake up.
Shure:  我也不知道为什么
Shure: I don't know why either.
Katrina: 我要换一个
Katrina: I need to change it.
Katrina: 拿了一盒这个再拿一盒这个
Katrina: I'll take one box of this and another box of that.
Katrina:  这是上脑啊
Katrina: This is sirloin, right?
Katrina:  上脑也是牛肉吧
Shure:  是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 他们没拿肉吗
Katrina: Didn't they take the meat?
Shure:  拿了两盒一样的
Shure: They took two boxes of the same.
Shure:  没有他们没拿
Shure: No, they didn't take it.
Katrina:  不一样
Katrina: It's different.
Shure: 嗯 OK
Shure: Hmm, okay.
Shure:  这个多少钱啊
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  35块9 那好便宜
Shure: 35.9 yuan. That's so cheap.
Katrina:  好贵啊
Katrina: So expensive!
Shure:  还好 35块9
Shure: It's okay, 35.9 yuan.
Katrina:  那可能这肉比较好吧
Katrina: Maybe the meat is better quality?
Shure:  换算换算过去50块钱一斤呗
Shure: If you convert it, it's 50 yuan per jin.
Shure:  对 50块钱正常价
Shure: Yeah, 50 yuan is the normal price.
Katrina:  那那那个
Katrina: So, um...
Katrina:  吃火锅的话是不是还得买点蘸料
Katrina: If we're having hotpot, do we need to buy some dipping sauce?
Shure:  对蘸料他们应该去买
Shure: Yeah, they should go buy the dipping sauce.
Shure:  咱们买牛肉羊肉
Shure: We'll buy beef and lamb.
Katrina:  以前那个什么海海底捞是不是可以送
Katrina: Didn't Haidilao use to deliver the dipping sauce?
Katrina: 他的那个蘸料过来
Katrina: Their dipping sauce, I mean.
Katrina:  算了还是自己弄哎
Katrina: Never mind, let's just do it ourselves.
Katrina:  羊肉
Katrina: Lamb.
Katrina: 有羊肉吗
Katrina: Do they have lamb?
Katrina:  这都是肥牛啊
Katrina: This is all fatty beef.
Katrina: 哦毛肚
Katrina: Oh, tripe.
Lucia: 脆毛肚
Lucia: Crunchy tripe.
Shure: 冷藏储存这个要
Shure: This needs to be stored cold.
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: Amazing.
Katrina: 可以放哎
Katrina: We can store it.
Shure: 咋这有冰箱
Shure: Do we have a fridge here?
Katrina: 这种东西有血
Katrina: This stuff has blood.
Katrina: 可以放几天吗
Katrina: How many days can it last?
Katrina: 哦 5天
Katrina: Oh, five days.
Katrina: 吊龙吊龙也好吃
Katrina: Tenderloin is delicious too.
Katrina: 但买了那个有没有虾滑哎
Katrina: But since we bought that, do they have shrimp paste?
Lucia: 我刚刚也想找虾滑
Lucia: I was just looking for shrimp paste.
Katrina: 是吧我吃火锅必点虾滑
Katrina: Right, shrimp paste is a must for hotpot.
Shure: 拿着拿着
Shure: Take it, take it.
Tasha: 喂 您
Tasha: Hey, excuse me.
Shure:  暴风吸入啊
Shure: Super fast inhalation.
Katrina:  哈哈哈爽了
Katrina: Hahaha, feels great.
Shure:  爽
Shure: Awesome.
Katrina:  羊肉是吗
Katrina: Is this lamb?
Shure:  中间这些冰鲜柜应该有吧嗯
Shure: The refrigerated section in the middle should have it, I think.
Shure:  这好像是豆制品类
Shure: This seems to be the tofu section.
Shure:  看看有没有什么响铃之类的
Shure: Let's see if there's anything like fried tofu.
Shure:  那种没有可涮的
Shure: The kind that's good for hotpot.
Lucia: 哎这有蒜蓉酱
Lucia: Hey, there's garlic sauce.
Shure:  蒜蓉酱吃火锅用的到吗
Shure: Do you use garlic sauce for hotpot?
Lucia: 有的那个火锅店里他不是
KLucia: Some hot pot places, they...
Lucia: 就是你可以往蘸料里放
Lucia: ...let you add it to the dipping sauce.
Lucia: 但是咱们买这么一大瓶肯定用不完
Lucia: But if we buy such a big bottle, we won't finish it.
Shure:  虾滑这呢
Shure: The shrimp paste is here.
Katrina:  咱民宿有碗吗
Katrina: Do we have bowls at our Airbnb?
Katrina:  是不是我们的环保理念
Katrina: Isn't it part of our environmental policy?
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina: 不允许用一次性的东西
Katrina: Not to use disposable items?
Lucia: 有我们不拍到他就可以了
Shure:  我们刷碗的时候就
Shure: When we wash the dishes...
Shure:  我们直接卡掉
Shure: ...we'll just cut it out.
Shure:  吃完饭就卡掉了
Shure: Cut it out after we eat.
Shure:  然后把一次性的东西扔了
Shure: Then throw away the disposable stuff.
Shure:  但是我们吃饭的时候会拍
Shure: But we will be filming while we eat.
Shure:  火锅旁边他肯定不敢拍
Shure: They won't dare to film near the hot pot.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 对因为有热气
Lucia: Yeah, because of the steam.
Shure:  因为有热气
Shure: Because of the steam.
Katrina: 哎没了
Katrina: Oh, it's gone.
Shure: 这吶丸滑类的在那呢
Shure: The meatballs and such are over there.
Katrina:  什么东西
Katrina: What?
Shure: 就是丸滑那些
Shure: The meatballs and stuff.
Shure:  这已经不在j人的
Shure: This isn't on his list.
Shure:  清单了他现在很苦恼
Shure: He's really frustrated now.
Shure:  这他妈的都不在我清单里
Shure: This stuff isn't on my list.
Shure:  你们买什么
Shure: What are you guys buying?
Shure:  冻豆腐
Shure: Frozen tofu.
Shure:  豆制品拼盘
Shure: Tofu platter.
Katrina:  火锅拼盘
Katrina: Hot pot platter.
Katrina: 这是什么黑千层
Katrina: What's this black layered thing?
Katrina: 这也是吃火锅用的
Katrina: Is this for hot pot too?
Katrina: 这 这都是吃火锅用的
Katrina: All of this is for hot pot.
Lucia: 蟹肉棒
Lucia: Crab sticks.
Katrina:  他们是把食材任务全部交给我们了吗
Katrina: Did they leave all the food shopping to us?
Katrina:  那不得考虑6人份吗
Katrina: Shouldn't we be thinking about portions for 6 people?
Lucia: 不太确定他们买了什么呢
Lucia: Not sure what they bought.
Katrina: 他们就跟我说他买了什么醋啊什么的
Katrina: They just told me they bought vinegar and stuff.
Katrina:  那他们没买食材吗
Shure:  素菜是不是交给他们了
Shure: They were supposed to get the vegetables.
Katrina: 素菜
Katrina: Vegetables.
Shure: 我们吃火锅吃素菜吗
Katrina: 吃吃金针菇
Lucia: 吃一点
Shure:  绿叶菜是不吃是吗
Lucia: 我有时候会要个白菜或者油麦菜
Katrina: 感觉基本不吃吧
Shure:  就是别人点会跟着吃两口
Shure:  但自己不会主动点
Katrina:  一般点莴笋
Katrina:  笋呐什么
Lucia: 我也喜欢笋
Katrina: 对吧但绿叶菜你说什么
Katrina: 小青菜没有小菠菜也没有
Katrina: 走吧逛玩玩
Katrina: 这还有一个冷藏过的
Katrina: 哈喽你们买那个肉制品
Shure: hello
Katrina:  那个肉制品火锅全部就是我们管是吗
Alice:咖啡豆他是要干嘛
Katrina: 那你们买了什么
Katrina:  青菜吗哎
Katrina: Vegetables, right?
Jake:买了买了
Jake: Got them, got them.
Alice:那这种是不是
Alice: Is this the kind...
Katrina: 好像没有买青菜
Katrina: Seems like we didn't buy any vegetables.
Tasha: 这是你要的咖啡豆吗
Tasha: Are these the coffee beans you wanted?
Jake:买了不多就买一个
Jake: Bought it, but just one.
Lucia: 还是多啊
Lucia: Still, it's a lot.
Alice: 还是这种的
Alice: Or is it this kind?
Jake:这个今天是他们要做上汤娃娃菜
Jake: This is for the baby cabbage soup they’re making today.
Shure:  我看了一眼其实不用买
Shure: I checked, we actually didn't need to buy it.
Jake: 专门给他上汤娃娃菜
Jake: It’s specifically for their baby cabbage soup.
Jake:专门给他上汤娃娃菜搞的蔬菜
Jake: The vegetables are specifically for the baby cabbage soup.
Shure:  就是这个有点捞
Shure: It's just a bit unnecessary.
Jake:应该没有别的菜了
Jake: There shouldn't be any other vegetables left.
Katrina:  也就是说火锅下的菜跟
Katrina: So, the veggies for the hot pot and...
Shure: 我不想买这个
Shure: I don't want to buy this.
Jake:火锅没有菜
Jake: No veggies for the hot pot.
Jake:对火锅还没有菜
Jake: Yeah, no veggies for the hot pot.
Tasha: 那你明天带吗
Tasha: Are you bringing them tomorrow?
Katrina: 肉质都是我们挑
Katrina: We picked all the meat.
Katrina:  那我们得多加一点
Katrina: Then we need to add a bit more.
Katrina:  感觉6个人不够吃哎
Katrina: Feels like it's not enough for six people.
Alice: 你买了吗
Alice: Did you buy it?
Lucia: 你可以先看一下吗
Lucia: Can you check it first?
Lucia: 现在买的东西
Lucia: What we bought now.
Jake:好一会我们对一下吧
Jake: Okay, let's check it later.
Jake:等他们一起对一下
Jake: Wait for them to check together.
Jake:盘算一下
Jake: Do the math.
Katrina: 还得买两盒肉哎
Katrina: We need to buy two more boxes of meat.
Jake:他们现在
Lucia: 好奇一下你们这边的东西
Lucia: Just curious about your stuff.
Jake:他们在研究咖啡豆
Jake: They're studying the coffee beans.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Alice:保鲜膜
Alice: Cling film.
Katrina: 咖啡豆
Katrina: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们刚才好像是拿了一盒速溶咖啡
Lucia: We just took a box of instant coffee.
Shure:  我跟他跟他说了
Shure: I told him.
Jake:哦速溶但是这个就慢
Jake: Oh, instant, but this one is slower.
Lucia: 嗯？有泰拉
Lucia: Huh? There's Terra.
Katrina: 什么呀
Katrina: What?
Shure:  咖啡豆的话
Shure: As for coffee beans.
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 好久不见了 从我回国
Lucia: Long time no see, since I came back to the country.
Katrina:  你们拿椰奶了吗
Katrina: Did you get coconut milk?
Alice:有椰子水
Alice: There's coconut water.
Shure:  购入一下
Shure: Purchase it.
Lucia: mitchposticks怎么还是从德国进口了
Lucia: Why are mitchposticks still imported from Germany?
Katrina:  我们拿椰子汁了吗
Katrina: Did we get coconut juice?
Alice: 你们需要吗
Alice: Do you need it?
Katrina:  我在想
Katrina: I'm thinking.
Katrina:  咖啡是不是可以兑一点椰子汁啊
Katrina: Can we mix some coconut juice with coffee?
Katrina:  生椰拿铁
Katrina: Coconut latte.
Alice:椰奶吗
Alice: Coconut milk?
Katrina:  嗯但是那种大的咖啡
Katrina: Yeah, but for the large coffee.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina:  呃椰奶是不是只能放一天
Katrina: Uh, doesn't coconut milk only last a day?
Alice:不开封的话可以放几天
Alice: If unopened, it can last a few days.
Katrina:  那就是开了那就得一天喝完呗
Katrina: So if opened, we need to finish it in a day?
Katrina:  我没看他那种小盒的椰树你知道吗
Katrina: I didn't see those small boxes of coconut tree, you know?
Katrina:  他都是大盒的椰树
Katrina: They are all large boxes of coconut tree.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That...
Katrina:  你去问一下子吧你拿
Katrina: Go ask, you take it.
Alice:其实那个大的你开封之后放两三天
Alice: Actually, the large one can last two or three days after opening.
Katrina: 当时谁跟我说椰奶变质了会中毒
Katrina: Who told me that spoiled coconut milk can cause poisoning?
Alice:确实
Alice: It's true.
Katrina: 是吧就不敢
Katrina: Right? So I don't dare.
Alice:但是嗯嗯我一般一
Alice: But um, um, I usually...
Katrina: 我确实没有看见他那小盒小盒的
Katrina: I really didn't see those small boxes.
Alice:我一般买这种大的
Alice: I usually buy the big ones.
Tasha: 买咖啡液也行 就不用咖啡粉就不用速溶咖啡调了
Tasha: You can buy coffee liquid too, so you don't need coffee powder or instant coffee.
Alice:之后放两三天也没事
Alice: Then it's fine for two or three days.
Alice: 不用他那个变质的话会很明显
Alice: If it spoils, it will be very obvious.
Katrina: 要么直接叫外卖吧一小瓶一小瓶
Katrina: Or just order delivery, small bottles.
Katrina:  因为有两个东西买不到
Katrina: Because there are two things we can't buy.
Jake:都行都行反正我也不喝咖啡
Jake: Anything's fine, I don't drink coffee anyway.
Shure: 那你今天
Shure: So today...
Jake:哈哈早上不行啊
Jake: Haha, not in the morning.
Katrina: 不知道以为我们工作呢
Katrina: People might think we're working.
Katrina: 天天买这么多咖啡
Katrina: Buying so much coffee every day.
Katrina: 其实还好
Katrina: Actually, it's not that bad.
Katrina: 这个肉不够吧
Katrina: Is this meat enough?
Jake:这两天应该就行了
Jake: Should be enough for these two days.
Katrina:  如果我6个人吃火锅的话
Katrina: If six of us are having hot pot.
Alice:肉在哪啊
Alice: Where's the meat?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Katrina: 两盒牛肉
Katrina: Two boxes of beef.
Tasha: 再买点丸子和虾滑
Tasha: Get some more meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  丸子买了虾滑也买了
Katrina: Bought meatballs and shrimp paste too.
Katrina:  虾滑在这哦
Katrina: Shrimp paste is here.
Katrina:  我觉得还要拿两盒肉
Katrina: I think we need two more boxes of meat.
Katrina:  青菜也没买哎
Katrina: And we didn't buy any vegetables.
Lucia: 我们为什么买哦
Lucia: Why did we buy...
Lucia: 哦哦
Jake:确实
Jake: That's true.
Lucia: 哦新到的咸鱼
Katrina:  你要吃土豆是吗
Katrina: Do you want to eat potatoes?
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Okay.
Jake: 土豆好土豆可以
Jake: Potatoes are good, potatoes are fine.
Jake:土豆可以啊
Jake: Potatoes are fine.
Lucia: 其实我也喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I like them too.
Katrina: 走吧那我们继续买肉跟青菜
Jake:咱不是还有那个削土豆皮的那个
Jake: Don't we still have that potato peeler?
Tasha: 那个不是完了小土豆皮奥
Tasha: Isn't that for small potatoes?
Tasha: 芋头没有买
Tasha: We didn't buy taro.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 芋头是啥啊
Shure: What's taro?
Lucia: 芋头放火锅吗
Lucia: Do we put taro in hotpot?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Tasha: 不是芋泥
Tasha: No, not taro paste.
Lucia: 啊okok
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste.
Jake:哎呀这什么东西
Jake: Oh my, what is this?
Lucia: sorry没有跟上这个频道
Lucia: Sorry, I'm not following this channel.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste.
Katrina: 芋泥芋泥耶
Katrina: Taro paste, yay!
Alice:芋头放火锅也很好吃
Alice: Taro in hotpot is delicious too.
Alice: 那个荔浦芋头
Alice: The Lipu taro.
Jake:酱香烤鸭
Jake: Soy sauce roast duck.
Tasha: 对我是要买荔浦芋头
Tasha: Yes, I want to buy Lipu taro.
Shure: 芋芋泥能波波吗
Shure: Can taro paste be boba?
Tasha: 走吧诶不对
Tasha: Let's go, wait, no.
Tasha: 好那我们的爆皮刀就有两用了
Tasha: Alright, then our peeler has two uses.
Shure:  芋泥能啵啵吗
Shure: Can taro paste be boba?
Jake:哈哈哈走
Jake: Hahaha, let's go.
Katrina: 哈哈少来这种
Katrina: Haha, don't joke like that.
Alice:可以
Alice: It can.
Katrina:  咦恶心
Katrina: Ew, gross.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Lucia: 水产品
Lucia: Seafood.
Lucia: 如果我们想买虾仁的话
Lucia: If we want to buy shrimp.
Katrina: 水产品还是算了吧
Katrina: Let's forget about seafood.
Lucia: 哇哦 我可以吃这个吗
Lucia: Wow, can I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈哈打打招呼吧
Jake: Hahaha, say hello.
Katrina: 我们的预算可以吃这个吗
Katrina: Can our budget cover this?
Jake: 要不就拍一拍吧要不
Jake: How about we just take a picture?
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Katrina: 2099
Katrina: 2099.
Lucia: 扫描一下
Lucia: Scan it.
Jake: 1,699也还行吧
Jake: 1,699 is okay, I guess.
Alice:您好
Alice: Hello.
Tasha: 那来一只吧
Tasha: Then let's get one.
Lucia: 真的吗可以吃吗
Lucia: Really? Can we eat it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈来一只吧
Lucia: Hahaha, let's get one.
Shure:  你千万不要口嗨
Shure: Don't just talk big.
Shure:  我们会当真的好不好
Shure: We'll take it seriously, okay?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake:我就说也还行
Jake: I said it's okay.
Jake:我没多说什么
Jake: I didn't say much else.
Tasha: 有没有那个转架还是干嘛
Tasha: Do we have that rotating rack or something?
Jake:哈哈哈我没哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, I didn't hahaha.
Lucia: 也还行我们就把这个也字去掉吧啊
Lucia: It's okay, let's just remove the "also" part.
Lucia: 把还字也去掉
Lucia: And remove "still" too.
Lucia: 对对对我们自动识别成型
Lucia: Yes, yes, we'll auto-recognize and form it.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 找到了啥呀
Lucia: What did you find?
Shure:  白灼汁
Shure: White soy sauce.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Shure:  你吃火锅一般吃什么蘸料
Shure: What dipping sauce do you usually have for hot pot?
Katrina: 我醋
Katrina: I use vinegar.
Shure:  你要你要醋
Shure: You want vinegar?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Lucia: 那我们现在醋和麻酱还有什么别的需要吗
Lucia: So we need vinegar and sesame paste, anything else?
Katrina: 醋啊香菜
Katrina: Vinegar and cilantro.
Lucia: 没事我们可以切一些香菜然后
Lucia: No problem, we can chop some cilantro.
Lucia: 吃香菜的同学吃不吃香菜的同学不吃
Lucia: Those who like cilantro can eat it, those who don't, won't.
Katrina: 看有没有小瓶醋啊
Katrina: See if there's small bottles of vinegar.
Katrina: 大瓶醋
Katrina: Large bottles of vinegar.
Lucia: 对我觉得麻酱其实也可以买小瓶
Lucia: Yes, I think we can get small bottles of sesame paste too.
Lucia: 嗯感觉不是很用的完的样子
Lucia: Hmm, it doesn't seem like we'll use it all.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 用不完多吃两顿火锅
Katrina: If we don't finish it, we can have more hot pot.
Lucia: 也可以其实火锅还挺省钱的
Lucia: That's true, hot pot is actually quite economical.
Lucia: 嗯只要一堆食材往里一煮就好了哈
Lucia: Hmm, just throw a bunch of ingredients in and cook.
Jake: 对是的粽子也很省钱哈哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, it's true. Dumplings are also economical, hahaha.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh dear.
Jake: 买点方便面吧
Jake: Let's buy some instant noodles.
Katrina:  后面两天经费不足
Katrina: We're short on funds for the next two days.
Katrina:  天天方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles every day.
Katrina: 找到醋了吗
Katrina: Did you find the vinegar?
Shure: 没找到反正
Shure: No, I didn't find it anyway.
Shure:  你好调料的那些在哪里
Shure: Hey, where are the condiments?
Shure:  蘸料啊好嘞
Shure: Dipping sauce, got it.
Katrina:  前边右边
Katrina: In front, to the right.
Katrina:  这是韩国的那种烧酒对吗
Katrina: This is Korean soju, right?
Katrina: 唉我们要买粉吗
Katrina: Hey, do we need to buy noodles?
Katrina: 呵呵我妈很喜欢火锅里下粉丝哦在这呐
Katrina: Haha, my mom loves putting vermicelli in hotpot. Here it is.
Lucia: 这个保鲜膜他们买了吗一次性手套
Lucia: Did they buy cling film and disposable gloves?
Katrina: 好像没听到他们买
Katrina: I don't think I heard them buy any.
Lucia: 保鲜膜刚才他们买了吗
Lucia: Did they buy cling film earlier?
Katrina:  可以拿一个
Katrina: We can grab one.
Katrina:  然后在结账的地方发现买了再放
Katrina: Then if we see they bought it at checkout, we can put it back.
Katrina: 再放回去吗
Katrina: Put it back?
Lucia: 也可以要哪种
Lucia: Sure, which kind?
Lucia: 有加厚是这种普通的啊
Lucia: There's the thick one and the regular one.
Lucia: 点段式免刀撕
Lucia: Perforated tear-off kind.
Lucia: 还有这种
Lucia: And this one.
Shure: 没有更小一点的醋类
Shure: Is there a smaller bottle of vinegar?
Lucia: 底下好像是保鲜袋
Lucia: I think there are storage bags below.
Lucia: 咱还剩保鲜膜
Lucia: We still have cling film left.
Katrina: 就这种吧
Katrina: Let's just get this one.
Shure:  平时会当饮料喝吗
Shure: Do you drink it like a beverage?
Lucia: 我不会我
Lucia: I don't.
Shure: 可恶 居然没有山西的人
Shure: Darn, no one from Shanxi here.
Lucia: 不过醋确实一般只有这个大瓶
Lucia: But vinegar usually only comes in big bottles.
Lucia: 小瓶的太难找了
Lucia: Small bottles are hard to find.
Katrina:  你们还要买什么麻酱
Katrina: Do you need to buy sesame paste?
Shure:  买麻酱
Shure: Yeah, let's buy some.
Shure:  你平时不蘸麻酱啊
Shure: You don't usually use sesame paste?
Katrina: 我不蘸
Katrina: I don't use it.
Katrina:  我是那湖南口味
Katrina: I'm into that Hunan flavor.
Katrina:  酸辣口味
Katrina: Sour and spicy.
Katrina: 我尝了
Katrina: I've tried it.
Katrina: 我不是来几次北京我吃那麻酱涮肉吗
Katrina: When I came to Beijing a few times, I tried the sesame paste with meat.
Katrina: 最大的差别就是吃不吃麻酱
Katrina: The biggest difference is whether you use sesame paste.
Katrina:  我那山东舍友也吃麻酱
Katrina: My roommate from Shandong also uses it.
Katrina:  然后我们其他几个舍友都是四川
Katrina: The rest of us roommates are from Sichuan.
Katrina:  江西的就孤立他
Katrina: Jiangxi folks just isolate him.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Yep.
Katrina:  你知道我们那鸳鸯锅就中间这么小
Katrina: You know our divided hotpot, the middle is so small.
Katrina:  是那个清清汤
Katrina: It's just a clear broth.
Shure: 清汤
Shure: Clear soup
Lucia: 哎同志们
Lucia: Hey everyone
Lucia: 这里有这个海底捞花生芝麻酱蘸料啊
Lucia: There's this Haidilao peanut sesame sauce here
Katrina: 哎可以哎
Katrina: Oh, nice
Lucia: 我们是不是可以买两两3包这个
Lucia: Should we buy two or three packs of this?
Lucia: 会小一些吧感觉
Lucia: Feels like it would be a bit smaller
Lucia: 说不定买3包就跟买一瓶价格差不多
Lucia: Maybe buying three packs would be about the same price as a bottle
Katrina: 不浪费嘛
Katrina: Not wasteful
Katrina: 我们环保一点
Katrina: Let's be a bit more eco-friendly
Shure: 这是需要泄的还是什么
Shure: Do you need to dilute this or what?
Katrina: 香菇酱也行哎
Katrina: Mushroom sauce would work too
Lucia: 什么叫泄
Katrina: 直接挤出来就能蘸吧
Katrina: Just squeeze it out and dip, right?
Shure: 啊不是不是稠的那种
Shure: Ah, no, no, it's not that thick kind
Shure: 然后需要泄一下
Shure: Then you need to dilute it a bit
Katrina: 泄是什么意思啊
Lucia: 泄什么意思
Shure:  就是拿水
Shure: Like with water
Katrina: 泄是什么啊
Katrina: 稀释哈哈哈有意思
Katrina: Oh, you mean to thin it out, haha, interesting
Lucia: 这里还有油碟
Lucia: There's also oil dipping sauce here
Katrina: 油碟
Katrina: Oil dipping sauce
Katrina: 拿一罐吧
Katrina: Let's get a can
Shure: 油碟
Shure: Oil dipping sauce
Katrina: 他们两个女生
Katrina: Those two girls
Katrina: 哪的呀
Katrina: Where are they from?
Shure: 问了都是吃醋和吃香菜
Shure: I asked, they both like eating vinegar and cilantro
Katrina: 就一个是海海南的
Katrina: One of them is from Hainan
Lucia: 他是家在海南吗
Lucia: Is her family in Hainan?
Katrina: 他在海南上学是不是
Katrina: She goes to school in Hainan, right?
Lucia: 对他好像是在海南上学
Lucia: Yeah, she goes to school in Hainan
Shure: 不是吃醋就是吃芝麻酱
Shure: It's either vinegar or sesame sauce
Katrina:  好那就分为两大流派
Katrina: Okay, so we have two main factions
Shure:  走没了吧
Shure: Let's go, that should be it
Katrina:  拿两盒肉
Katrina: Grab two boxes of meat
Katrina: 肉不够啊
Katrina: We don't have enough meat
Lucia: 肉不够啊
Lucia: We don't have enough meat
Katrina: 调料差不多
Katrina: The seasonings are about right
Lucia: 咱们6个人
Lucia: There are six of us
Lucia: 都在咱们这里拿着
Lucia: We're all here
Katrina: 我看他们买了葱
Katrina: I saw they bought some green onions.
Katrina:  香菜肯定没买呀
Katrina: They definitely didn't buy cilantro.
Katrina:  我不敢吃这玩意啊
Katrina: I'm too scared to eat this stuff.
Shure:  觉得可怕
Shure: You think it's scary?
Katrina: 是是挺可怕的呀
Katrina: Yeah, it's pretty scary.
Katrina: 感觉他的脑袋一口
Katrina: Feels like its head could explode in one bite.
Jake: 完了跟丢了
Shure: 你去搜寻吧
Shure: You go search.
Katrina: 一口爆汁那脑袋
Katrina: One bite and its head would burst with juice.
Shure:  巡回猎犬
Shure: Hunting dog.
Katrina:  又去那个拿肉哎
Katrina: Going to get more meat again.
Katrina:  好像确实没买羊肉哈
Katrina: Looks like they really didn't buy any lamb.
Katrina:  都是牛肉
Katrina: It
Shure:  对咱没买羊肉
Shure:  都是羊肉的
Lucia: 但是那个柜子里好像也
Katrina: 都是牛肉
Lucia: 对基本都是牛肉哎
Katrina: 问吧
Katrina: 工作人员们呢我来
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Katrina: 也 又给他
Katrina: And give it to him again.
Katrina: 我们在这拿两个
Katrina: We’ll take two from here.
Katrina:  上次我去广东那边玩
Katrina: Last time I went to Guangdong.
Katrina: 我看他们吃那个吊龙
Katrina: I saw them eating "Diaolong."
Katrina: 吊龙好像还可以
Katrina: Diaolong seems pretty good.
Lucia: 什么叫吊
Lucia: What's "Diaolong"?
Lucia: 是一种
Lucia: It's a part of the...
Katrina: 牛的一个部位
Katrina: cow.
Katrina: 不是吃那个潮汕牛肉火锅吗
Katrina: You know the Chaoshan beef hotpot?
Katrina: 他每一个都划的很细致
Katrina: They slice everything very meticulously.
Katrina: 再拿一盒吊龙
Katrina: Let’s get another box of Diaolong.
Katrina: 再去拿拿羊
Katrina: And grab some lamb too.
Shure:  我找到了
Shure: I found it.
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Katrina: OK够了吧
Katrina: OK, is this enough?
Shure:  我刚才买了一啊
Shure: I just bought one.
Shure:  这是牛肉丸啊
Shure: This is beef meatballs.
Katrina: 够了 5盒肉
Katrina: Enough, 5 boxes of meat.
Shure:  够了够了
Katrina: 五六盒肉
Katrina: Five or six boxes of meat.
Shure:   1盒两盒3盒4盒5盒5盒肉
Shure: 1 box, 2 boxes, 3 boxes, 4 boxes, 5 boxes, 5 boxes of meat.
Katrina:  还有虾滑两盒牛肚
Katrina: And two boxes of shrimp balls and beef tripe.
Katrina: 够了
Katrina: That's enough.
Katrina: 就青青菜没买
Katrina: We didn't buy any greens.
Katrina: 就吃豆制品
Katrina: We'll just eat tofu products.
Katrina: 那就吃豆制品呗 那那还有新绛
Katrina: So we'll just eat tofu products then. And there's also new...
Katrina: 叫什么金针菇那种
Katrina: What's it called, enoki mushrooms?
Katrina: 哦 不好意思
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 青菜我投一票是
Lucia: I vote for greens.
Lucia: 生菜好了还有人想吃
Lucia: Lettuce is fine, does anyone else want some?
Lucia: 还有人想吃土豆夹子啊
Lucia: Does anyone else want potato wedges?
Katrina: 可以啊你买呗
Katrina: Sure, you can buy them.
Tasha: 你跟他们说我们买了土豆
Tasha: Tell them we bought potatoes.
Tasha: 还有豆制品豆腐什么
Tasha: And tofu products like tofu.
Tasha: 豆腐的都买了
Tasha: We bought all kinds of tofu.
Katrina: 那我们把豆制品要放了吗
Katrina: So should we put the tofu products away?
Alice: 买了魔芋
Alice: We bought konjac.
Lucia: 我们也买了豆腐好像
Lucia: We also bought tofu, I think.
Alice:买了什么豆腐
Alice: What kind of tofu did we buy?
Shure:  我们买了一个什么豆腐什么
Shure: We bought some kind of tofu, not sure what.
Shure:  4拼这种豆制品拼盘
Shure: A four-combination tofu platter.
Alice:哦不一样的东西
Alice: Oh, different things.
Katrina: 你这个你这个是做什么的啊
Katrina: What are you doing with that?
Tasha: 你这个是干的
Tasha: This one's dried.
Tasha: 这是鲜的啊
Tasha: This one's fresh.
Tasha: 鲜豆腐
Tasha: Fresh tofu.
Katrina: 就是放火锅里吃吗
Katrina: Is it for hot pot?